Dude,
what did you call me?
He stopped talking like that.
I have a philosophical question.
Ooh,
I love those.
Go ahead.
Do you think our social station is circle mountable or is it a mutable Oh,
good question.
Immutable.
Oh no,
but don't you think we can overcome our circumstances given sufficient cutting
and skill?
No.
No I don't,
but I'm not like you yearning.
The fly beyond nature is boundaries.
Like some sort of disabled nerd ICARUS.
Anyway,
why do you ask?
Oh,
no reason.
Buckingham,
but Barbie,
it's just that,
uh,
I've got plans for a date a day.
You,
who's going to date you?
Well,
I was thinking of grabbing a date to the city.
Hawkins.
No,
I get it.
You think by going to the dance,
you'll seem like less of a creepy renaissance.
Fair talking Weirdo.
We'll and Ri specify circumstance.
Yes.
I can help if you want.
Oh,
do you want to go with native dance?
Not as like a date or whatever,
but it was like friends or pass whatever.
Jerk face.
So like I want it to be that matchy matchy disabled cover.
Fine.
That's fine.
Okay.
You do know this 80 Hawkins dance is where the girl asks the guy out.
Right.
And I'm like the only girl that talks to you.
Oh,
that's fine.
I was thinking of going with an
and Margaret,
but she's the most popular girl.
Formerly the most popular.
Eddie broke up with her over winter break.
So what?
She's still super out of your league.
Is She buck?
Is she,
or maybe it's just that you don't know what league that I'm in?
No,
she's out of your league.
She's hot.
She's smart.
She's super talented.
You know she's a professional dancer,
but now she's in wounded bird mode.
See if I can get her to ask me to the dance,
then I will instantly vault paths my current inglorious station and for once
people might see me.
Oh,
Richard had to ask Andrew the dance.
That would already be a humiliating rejections situation.
But getting her to ask you,
I mean,
what's your angle if gnosis or cash plus why Eddie's ex girlfriend?
Is it like a copycat day revenge thing,
sex thing?
Is it a sexual bench copycat thing?
Wait,
where's your,
is this a scheme?
What you always scheming.
Ha Ha.
Are you running for president?
What
is getting a day with Ann Margaret?
The first step is some elaborate multistep scheme for getting elected senior
class president.
It is,
isn't it?
No,
it's not a scheme.
I just want to date.
Yeah.
And I want Chris Evans to sit on my face.
Only he has to ask.
Well,
who's Chris?
Chris Evans is Captain America.
He's been captain America for like 19 movies.
I'm sorry.
Do you watch movies or you're too busy?
Tune into the voices inside your head.
Softer.
Soft.
Do now who talks like that?
Whatever path.
Follow your dreams.
Well,
books,
right?
Of course.
Landing a date with Ann.
Margaret is part of an elaborate multistep scheme.
If I can capture Eddie's ex girlfriend,
the people will know that I am the most redoubtable nave.
Someone who's not to be fucking with.
And so Roseland high school.
Prepare for your feet.
My first step to power is to land a first date.
Oh,
and I believe you had something you wanted to ask me.
I did.
Aha.
So go ahead.
I really can't think of anything.
Can you get out of my way?
Oh nope.
That's not it.
I don't know what your deal is,
but I'm not into guessing games,
Richard.
Oh,
this isn't a game.
It's an invitation.
So go ahead and bite me to say the Hawkins.
All you have to do is ask,
oh,
excuse me.
Look,
I know you're differently abled,
but you got to know that's not happening.
Um,
because I don't like you.
You don't even know me.
I mean,
we've known each other since middle school,
but this is the most that we've talked.
You're right.
I don't know you.
So why would I ask you out?
Cause I pity you.
Whoa.
No one's asking for pity here.
Why do you pity me?
Or do you fear me?
Are you afraid you'll contract cerebral palsy just by the very tainted my touch.
See,
you hate me for what I am.
No,
I don't.
I just,
Richard,
I don't mean to be mean.
I'm just trying to stay in my lane here.
You know?
Well,
which is it?
And pity me,
hate me or fear me.
I don't even know you.
I nothing you there.
Exactly.
I'm not even relevant here.
See,
the real reason you're going to ask me to save you Hawkins is because it's the
best way to get back in Eddie,
Eddie.
But I don't want to get back at Eddie really.
Even though he was hardcore dating you all through winter break,
only to immediately start dating Liz Woodville Eddie's dating Liz.
No,
he's not.
Clearly you don't follow Lids Woodville on Instagram.
Okay.
Whatever hits done now he can date who he wants.
I've seen you on campus in seeing the happy go lucky social butterfly cocooning
herself in a Chrysalis of melancholy and doubt.
Yeah.
Well it's been a really hard year,
but which is why it's so brave of you soldiering on like this.
You know something in,
I've never known the tender pleasures of dating really,
but then again,
I've never been unceremoniously dumped.
That's okay.
Is that what people are saying?
Well that's right,
and he's still the most popular person in school where it's you.
You were nothing now nothing.
I'm just me.
Well,
being you isn't enough.
Not In this rose land wasteland.
If Eddie and Liz Woodville go to the dance,
what's your counter attack?
You even need a counter attack.
I swear to God.
High school drama.
Such bullshit asked me to dance.
If you go with me,
everyone will see what a good person you are that you did the selfless good deed
of taking Richard the cripple to his very first dance.
I'm your charm offensive.
Okay.
If I did go with you,
I'd only be doing it to be a good person.
It doesn't mean that we're like dating.
Not ever.
Yeah.
God.
Richard,
what kind of crazy fantasies go on in that hat?
So many and you have no idea.
So what's it going to be?
Fine,
Richard will you got a Sadie Hawkins with me?
Yeah.
No,
no.
You fucking ass crack.
Go to the dance with you.
And because I never learned how to dance.
Oh,
well
could I teach you or something?
I do have a dance background.
Hit the date,
but it's not
too spicy and me thinks the lady does protest too much.
Hi,
I think I'm protesting.
Just write.
Hey Man.
Jesus what?
You're a good person.
Thanks.
Did you fucking fee that
every woman's so easily.
One.
We're going to be like Lancelot and Gwinner view Pyramus and Thisbe,
Michelle and Barack
[inaudible].
Um,
I'm Greg most gala and,
uh,
I'm thinking Richard.
Nice.
Thanks Charlie.
Hi,
I'm Tiffany Villarin and I'm playing and Margaret.
Yeah,
I'm Rhonda Anderson and I play Elizabeth,
Ms. York,
also known as Miss Shore.
Okay.
Uh,
I'm Shannon Devito and I play buck.
Wonderful.
Well,
I hope you all enjoyed the gene.
Uh,
I know some people have actually been to the show already.
If you haven't,
go get your ticket to now selling out really fast and they've already announced
an extension actually,
so you can go and get tickets.
Um,
so teenage Dick is a modern retelling of Richard Third,
Shakespeare's Richard the third.
You'll probably recognize some of the dialogue.
Um,
so let's talk about the title,
right?
I know it caused a little bit of hand wringing.
Um,
Craig,
you actually commissioned the play from Mike Lou.
That's right.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and he mentioned in the video,
right?
It was that,
it was as simple as that.
I just,
um,
thought,
uh,
Mike,
I want you to write Richard the third set in high school,
uh,
and call it teenage deck.
So,
um,
yeah,
so I,
I run a theater company called the empathy team.
We focused on plays that,
um,
we produce,
works that explore and eliminate the disabled experience,
um,
which is really an exploration to figure out what that is.
Um,
and I thought,
you know,
Richard,
the third is arguably the most famous disabled character in western dramatic
literature.
So he's a great character.
Just sort of take on and explore.
You mentioned,
uh,
at the CTA,
um,
where,
where did that name come from?
So,
uh,
the inspiration for the,
the namesake of the company,
there was a disabled playwright,
a named John.
So,
uh,
who had worked in theater extensive.
Liam was all,
uh,
also writing for.
So I was like deadwood on Hbo and some network shows.
Um,
he actually passed away in 2006 and in 2007,
I was in the New York Premiere,
uh,
of a show of his called the rules of charity.
And a character actually mentions the [inaudible],
uh,
which was a split,
a place in ancient Sparta in Greece,
uh,
where,
you know,
the Spartans were known for their very sort of fascistic,
um,
physical worldview,
right?
Uh,
they were very militaristic society.
So if you don't,
if you didn't fit that worldview,
the empathy tay was a place,
a chasm in the ground were disabled and deformed infants where we're left to the
elements.
Um,
so roughly translates to the place of exposure.
and I'm just like,
I thought that was a really beautiful,
and I'm,
so I'm playing on that double entendre to shed light into dark places and also
exposed or make visible,
uh,
sort of,
and is able to experience or make the history of disabled people more visible.
And we talked a little bit earlier about authentic Caspi.
Um,
and if we think about stories that,
that feature disabled character so often these narratives fallen a very few
limited number of buckets,
you know,
inspirational,
overcoming adversity.
Why do you think the narratives are so pervasive in our culture?
Whoa.
Uh,
I,
that's a,
that's a big question.
Well,
I think,
again,
this is a incredibly representational cast,
right?
Uh,
and like,
um,
I think that was intentional.
And,
and by partnering with my EA,
which is an Asian American theater company,
right?
Um,
we have,
uh,
this incredible cast and production team that is,
a diverse,
uh,
ethnically,
gender ability.
Um,
it just all kinds of ways,
which is really great.
I think I'm,
and I can't speak on the,
uh,
being Asian American or African American,
but,
uh,
from a disability perspective,
I think disability is very hard to deal with.
I mean,
there's a lot of anxiety around the issue in the topic.
It's not discussed or hasn't been discussed as openly as,
uh,
the experience of other marginalized groups because that work is being done for,
um,
for decades and decades and decades now.
And we're,
we're disabilities behind in that regard.
Um,
but the pervasive narratives are being an inspiration,
overcoming adversity or death with dignity,
you know,
and I think,
um,
those are sort of the three that I would,
three buckets that I would put these in.
Um,
I don't know,
not to be a downer,
but I think disability is the context of disability is not a geographic location
or like a specific culture.
Right.
But the,
the,
the context of disability is illness,
trauma,
pain and death.
So,
um,
that's difficult.
That can be difficult to deal with because it is,
uh,
it reminds me one of their own vulnerability and ultimately their own mortality.
I think,
um,
which again is that can be a pill to swallow,
but I think there's great,
uh,
that can be seen as a deficit or that can be seen as a great strength,
you know,
because if someone has undergone trauma,
becomes disabled,
that's difficult.
Yes.
But the other,
the flip side of that is that they've had an encounter with death and beat it.
And I think there's great,
there's great strength in that.
Um,
and so I'm interested in focusing on both the dark and the light and all the
spaces in between.
Excellent.
Now you mentioned,
um,
my age very focused on,
on diversity and representation in the arts in general.
Um,
not just on stage but,
but a offstage as well.
And the crew and in writing and directing,
um,
there's been a lot of,
of stories in the media lately about movies in particular and TV,
um,
and representation in those roles either be a traditional role being played by
white actor.
Um,
how,
you know,
and,
and Shannon and I were having a quick conversation about this earlier and you
never want to take work away from people,
but you also want to be in control of your,
the narrative that you identify with.
Uh,
so how do you guys kind of handle that in,
in your day to day in,
in,
in going to cat scan calls and choosing productions you've work on?
Hmm.
I think,
um,
one of the reasons why I love being an actor in New York is my theater because
they are the largest gathering of Asian American playwrights in history in the,
in the country,
in the world.
And
MMM.
And I feel very fortunate to be able to have gotten to know a lot of them,
a lot of those playwrights,
and to be in on the ground level of new works that they're creating.
Um,
because that conversation about representation and about being in charge of our
narratives and not having the narrative always be about explaining my race for
white people,
frankly,
you know,
is,
is at the top of,
of that awareness for those writers.
And,
um,
and it's,
it's important work I think,
to be,
to be doing.
And,
and Mike is,
is,
he's the,
he's the head of the head of,
he's the head of the Myers writers laugh right now.
And,
um,
uh,
and I think that this play in particular is doing all of those things on all the
different levels,
not just about race,
but also about ability and disability and,
and,
um,
it also happens to be incredibly smart and funny.
Yeah.
And it's hard and it's funny and that's,
you know,
yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
It's all of those levels of things.
And it's Shakespeare.
So,
you know,
people who laugh at the funny inside Shakespeare jokes are,
I'm like,
Oh,
you're the,
you're the Shakespeare nerd.
I hear you.
You know,
I was like,
so
all in there.
Um,
and that's the work that I want to be in.
And I that I think is the future of like what audiences want to experience or,
or like that's the possibility.
That's where theater could go.
Yep.
We're storytelling could go in that direction.
Yeah.
Great.
Oh,
um,
anything you want to add?
I know I agree with that.
Um,
yeah,
I mean,
being an actor,
going into these auditions,
you know,
a lot of the times,
you do get into a play and a lot of the times they're not really,
um,
welcoming of your experience as,
as it for me as a black woman into the room,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
Yay,
we want to be diverse,
Yay.
But you know what I mean?
Can I also bring myself into it as well?
And that's not been this experiences at all.
It's so inclusive and I feel very welcomed and feel very represented and,
and,
and not in a way of like,
I'm glad you get an he just like,
I'm a teacher and I'm doing my job.
You know what I mean?
I don't have to explain it.
Yeah.
Look at what you were saying.
You don't have to explain what I am,
where I am.
Um,
and,
and with this play,
it's just,
it's just all,
like you said,
it's all there.
It's just brilliant and so easy to dive into and have so much fun.
So I felt very welcome.
Brenda,
you,
you mentioned that you play,
uh,
the teacher.
Yes.
You work,
um,
he,
your character,
you guys really should go watch the play.
Your character has these really great moments where you're,
you're cringing at at kind of some of the moment and then you're just laughing
out loud.
Um,
you,
you know,
I don't,
I'm not going to give any spoilers,
but you have,
oh,
I'm cringing.
You're cringing kind of some of the,
the,
the lines and the,
and the gestures.
Um,
but then toward the latter end of this show,
you have this spectacular kind of solo moment where I feel like Ms. York really
kind of finds her own.
Um,
you're awesome.
Kind of the only adults in the room,
if you will.
You know,
everyone else.
She's a high school teenager.
Um,
so we'll be it like kind of playing that adult in such an ensemble show.
it's funny cause I was like,
Oh,
this is so fun.
It's like,
you know,
set in high school.
And I were,
I don't actually know how old everyone is.
I assume we're all in actually the same age ish.
Um,
but,
um,
I was like,
Oh yeah,
we get to play teens.
I'm like,
oh no,
I have to be the adult that person.
And it's funny because I'm also the deputy and I'm also putting the fire
captain.
So it's funny having all the responsibility all of a sudden became the
responsible one,
which is not to do it as Marinda.
So,
but um,
it's funny how that just kind of seeped on over.
Um,
but it's,
it's,
it's been fun.
I've actually never heard.
Oh,
we deserve and we get when we're ready.
Thank you.
All right.
Um,
I never felt like the adult in the room though during rehearsal.
I just felt like one of the clowns and just so,
you know,
having fun.
So it's,
it's,
I don't really feel the teacher,
I mean in those moments of like,
Oh God,
what is she doing?
I'm like,
oh,
very,
that's when the awareness comes in,
I guess.
Um,
but it's just such an ensemble.
I don't really feel like,
oh,
I'm like the adults playing the adult here.
But,
um,
yeah.
Did I answer your question about it?
Now?
You mentioned you're a deputy and a fire
fire
hold it very well.
No,
I'm a,
I'm the,
I'm there,
we are in a union actors Equity Union and each show has a deputy.
So it's like,
if anything,
any troubles arise,
they come to me and I told them,
don't come to me,
don't do it.
But it's always that thing at the beginning of rehearsals were like,
who wants to be the deputy?
And was like,
well yeah,
I did it before.
I don't really need to do it again.
And so I just went ahead and volunteered and then I also became the fight
captain to make sure people stay safe.
Wow.
There are a few little tiffs in the show,
so I just make sure we say safe.
Gotcha.
Now you had mentioned early,
you know,
you have a fight call earlier before the shell.
Um,
and there are some fight seems dancing's there's,
there's a lot of query raf kind of elements to the show.
What kind of special training did you guys have to go through to prepare for
that?
You know,
the choreographer he brought in kind of,
what was that experience like?
Well,
we have a,
so neither a TIF TIF.
I have a dance background.
Right.
So it's,
um,
but,
uh,
I mean I have had experience,
I was in a dance piece several years ago.
Um,
but that was it.
I mean,
I was hired as an actor to be in that dance piece and handling sort of learn all
those skills.
Um,
but this was a very different style.
I mean,
it's,
um,
all great high school story should end at a high school dance and,
you know,
teenage stick does.
Um,
and so,
um,
and they're really,
I mean,
again,
you saw on that scene,
it's like their relationship,
most of their scenes take place within an stance studio a where she is teaching
Richard how to dance and,
and they meet through the body,
right.
And develop.
I think it's really beautiful in life what he's constructed here because they
develop this really incredible level of intimacy.
Um,
that isn't,
um,
that later becomes sort of romantic but doesn't start that way.
Um,
but yeah,
we've had,
we had two incredible choreographers,
uh,
Jen Webber,
who worked on my production,
um,
God k-pop,
right.
Which was about a Korean pop,
Korean prophesying and um,
and Liz Tenuto,
uh,
associate choreographer.
Um,
and we just,
uh,
yeah,
we started every rehearsal with 90 minutes of dance.
Yeah.
So the first week I was like,
oh my God,
these muscles are hurting.
And that were just built it up where like,
okay,
I can do that.
But again,
I'm in what,
that's what the difference between dancers and actors,
his dancers practice their craft every day.
Like,
if you're not in a show,
you go and you,
you go to the bar and like you go,
you take a class,
like actors aren't that decision
plenty also go to a bar.
Right?
Right now we're at the bar.
While yeah,
we
find them later.
I come from a long line of people who have never picked up for it.
So,
um,
yeah.
Yeah,
I think it's,
I,
it's just,
it's just another element to the play again,
I think because at the high school nature of it,
the ending at prom or like the big spring fling or whatever,
you know,
you,
you have to have that.
And Mike said in a conversation of the day that he,
because of Richard,
the third ends of the battle,
the battle of Bosworth is the big climactic event.
Right.
And so he said he was transplanting sort of the world of the high school dance
into the Shakespearean sort of battle.
And I thought that was really,
really amazing.
Um,
I just really like,
I just really loved that idea.
So,
but yeah,
we,
but we drilled and drilled and drilled,
excellent movement.
His structure is such a scene of the show in,
in different ways.
Actually,
Shannon,
um,
I know we tied about this earlier,
but you had a really funny role and on the Hulu show rip a difficult people will
pour one out for,
for difficult people that really,
they cast you as a comedian written for someone in a wheelchair.
It was cashed for comedian.
Uh,
and then in this role,
buck is traditionally played by men.
And you're in these woman,
um,
originally,
man.
Yeah,
there's little boy.
Oh boy.
Right.
Why known Shannon for a couple years prior to this and I'm,
I,
Mike did not know her.
So she was all always from the genesis of the,
it was like we're going to use Shannon,
the veto.
But I think,
um,
yeah,
we,
Mike wasn't sure,
but it's you can,
but as soon as he discovered how wonderful Shannon was,
um,
it was,
uh,
a match.
I was allowed to be a hero.
Um,
so in this show you kind of bring this,
this robust free interpretation to the role,
um,
and your,
your cash kind of for your talent as an actor,
but you bring this really wonderful,
um,
almost some secondary character with you to the stage.
You know,
and we've brought up before Shannon high suspicion crepes scene where she's
giving Richard the finger and rolling away and it's just epic fade
really,
really well done.
Your comedic timing,
they show I'm on point.
Um,
so how did you kind of bring that,
that unique choreography to the role and how did you work with the other actors
in the choreographers to kind of stage that?
Um,
that's a very interesting question because I don't think about it.
Uh,
it,
I didn't really work with the choreographers at all.
It's kind of,
um,
it's funny cause a lot of the reviews also touched on that though.
It's just kind of part of the,
the world of,
of kind of how I live in.
And I loved that they are kind of seeing that because a wheelchair is often kind
of put into this world where it's a hindrance or wheelchair bound is often a
term that is used that we need staff music.
But it is,
and that it like you're tied to it and this horrible thing.
But like I love that people are noticing that it's so freeing and it's a part of
me.
It's,
I don't,
it's just kind of like I don't need,
it flows through me.
Like people,
actors often talk about being in their bodies when they're acting.
And I,
I feel like for so many years when I was in acting classes,
they wanted me to be like in just my body and I appreciate that.
But I feel like my wheelchair is an extension of that.
And,
um,
I,
I really get the ability to kind of utilize that on the stage in,
in the show.
And,
um,
I think a lot of my comedy comes through like with that.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it's pretty cool that,
that I got that ability to show people that it's not a hindrance.
It's actually a freeing,
wonderful thing.
The comment on how people respond to the reviews.
Is there reviews?
Visa been fantastic,
you know,
but again,
I think people are amazed that I can dance,
you know?
Uh,
and I think,
and that's not,
I'm not,
uh,
I'm not sort of calling anybody out,
but this sort of idea,
I think it's just,
you haven't seen it,
right.
There are plenty of amazing,
uh,
actors and dancers.
There's a dancer named Alice Shepherd is a wheelchair.
Dancers were on the cover of dance magazine this month.
You know,
um,
you just haven't,
it's not in a sort of cultural zeitgeist,
like it hasn't been shared or displayed as much.
So people,
it's so new.
It's almost revelent revelent tour.
Right.
And again,
the,
the sort of vocabulary,
the language about how into,
right.
I think if you just saw it more and more and more and more,
uh,
that would fade away.
And people would just say,
Shannon is a,
uh,
physical and verbal,
comedic,
you know,
uh,
actor,
and she has a great genius in that sense.
And I,
uh,
you know,
I consider myself an a rigorous physical actor because
all,
I mean,
I throw myself around all the time,
you know,
uh,
um,
but people seem so amazed that I,
and it's just a,
it's just a common conception about disability.
So amazing that you can get to the store or like,
you know,
get to your job or have a life or whatnot.
And,
uh,
if the theater is just sort of a reflection of our lives,
then oh my God,
look what these people can do on stage.
I think that's why the having the narratives,
right,
that are more,
more nuanced,
uh,
um,
more,
more thought out again,
where the disabled people themselves have agency and can inhabit a roles that
are closer to themselves actually helped to move that needle forward.
And it starts a discussion.
I mean,
we're having a discussion right now about this,
right?
And this is,
this discussion itself is pretty unprecedented.
Like,
I never imagined I would be at Google,
like talking about a play that game to life with these incredible people,
you know?
Uh,
so I just think that's,
but again,
it's,
it's about proximity and it's just about visibility and,
and again,
why I think my e right.
And,
and,
and work within the African American community,
within the theater community,
any marginalized group.
Right.
They understood we have to tell our own stories,
right.
Or our own stories in partnership with others,
but the plays and the plays and the plays and the plays that the narrative is
what is what moves,
move the culture forward.
Um,
and then,
and then hopefully society forward to when it's working well together.
They're both moving like this.
You mentioned the agency would use actually sometime like to talk to Tiffany
about,
um,
women in,
in Shakespearean plays are often side characters,
particularly in Richard the third,
they tend to fill a role of a crime morning victim.
Um,
micro,
the role is very differently.
He gave a lot of meat to your role in particular.
And,
and as the play goes,
you really,
your character changes kind of the tone and the direction of some of the show.
Um,
how did you,
you know,
without revealing anything,
um,
how did you kind of bring that agency and that ultimately that power to your
role as an,
um,
again,
I think this roots to being able to be in the room with a new play at the
inception or very near to and having,
um,
relationships with playwrights who are,
who are alive and,
and like writing for you in a way.
Shakespeare died so long ago and like,
he didn't write anything for me,
I feel,
you know,
um,
and um,
but it's getting to sit with Mike and saying like,
Hey,
I think she's smarter than that.
I think she's gotten more grip than we,
you know,
like we were able to have those conversations and Mike is like kind of
playwright who was open to having that with all of us about all of the roles
about what we think is authentic to that character.
And,
um,
and we were getting rewrites and previews.
We got to a whole new scene.
We were,
we'd already done three previews and got a new scene and put it up,
you know,
and,
um,
and it is high.
I feel very blessed to be able to s to stand on the public stage and say
something like,
I am not a tossed off afterthought like in a Shakespeare play or all the women
are a bunch of objects and character foils and plot devices.
And,
and it's,
and I get to do that and I get to say that and look at women in the audience and
see it and see it reflected back to me.
And that I think is a really special moment and something that is under the
whole piece,
this idea of agency.
And,
um,
and it's,
we,
something we had talked about too is,
you know,
Mike started writing this play four or five years ago before this big cultural
turn that we've had in,
in,
in the me too movement and all of that and how like even the,
and,
and Mike has a lot of pop culture references in his play plays that change,
that keep changing with time.
And that's another thing like saying that delivering that monologue now was
different than when I did it in a workshop two years ago.
You know,
and getting to,
um,
dig in,
in intuit in those layers has been,
is very powerful I think,
and feels good.
Like it's something that I think needs to be seen on stage.
Yeah.
You mentioned you were still getting new change in line changes up through
previews.
Yeah.
Um,
and I know you and Miranda have actually both done and,
and Shannon who had both on TV,
both of you were on Gotham.
Um,
I don't know if there was any overlap there,
but how has that project from doing,
you know,
TV,
episodic TV or kind of one off roll?
He compared the live theater.
I know you've all,
she would done multi,
multi format work,
but it kind of what he's about crossing,
like that's different.
I love theater.
I mean it's,
there's nothing like it.
Um,
TV is cool too.
it,
it's very cool.
I mean I'm,
I'm wanting to do more of it as well.
And I mean,
you know,
everyone gets to see it.
You get more,
you know,
exposure or whatever that way as well.
But,
and I,
I mean,
I love both mediums by theater,
just to be with people.
It's about like community and like reaching people and it's making contact,
um,
that you can't do through a screen.
MMM.
So I mean in the preparation is totally different.
I feel like when I get so nervous,
like if I have to be on a set,
it's like,
just know your lines and just say,
you know,
your two lines,
Mr President or you know,
whatever.
And um,
I,
it's actually very nerve wracking to me sometimes.
But,
um,
but with theater,
I mean,
it's alive in the great thing.
It's like these two,
they're so good.
He's so good.
Like just being spontaneous on the spot.
Like he responds to the audience,
like someone sneezed and he was like,
bless you.
Like,
you know what I mean?
You that you can do and it's so amazing and I just,
I love it.
It makes me so excited when those things happen.
Um,
yeah.
So that's how I feel about it.
Anybody else want to,
she was,
speaking of multi-format Shannon,
when are we going to get more installations in your youtube series?
Actually,
why don't you tell everyone,
I'll give you a little background on why you created that,
um,
and kind of what,
what you were doing with it and then tell me when we get more.
Um,
so I have a web series on youtube called stare at Shannon.
And I started it because I was bored and
I was like,
hey,
we really funny if I went through,
I drive through and my wheelchair and filmed it.
And then I friend was,
I was like,
call my friend.
Hey,
do this.
And he was like,
sure.
And so he did.
And so we went through the drive through and dirty Jerry fell day.
And then I was like,
oh,
I should do more of this cause I'm bored a lot.
And um,
but in reality,
uh,
the reason I wanted you to do more,
because I have this phrase word,
I'm like,
well,
people are staring at me anyway.
I might as well be doing something cool.
And so,
um,
so yeah,
so I do all kinds of weird things like go to a grocery store and eat food and
see what I can get away with.
Um,
which is terrific.
I did for,
I was very sick.
Uh,
cause I ate everything.
I ate a cake.
I made no did you just opened it up at the end?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I,
I,
but I just liked him openings up.
Uh,
the like the people at the store would help me like that.
I made a Sunday,
I poured a bowl of cereal.
I like,
it just made a sandwich.
I just went to town and like no one's had me.
They all help.
I was like,
all right.
And so I just,
Oh God,
I hate a whole cake.
It was some ridiculous,
every time you take suggestions.
Yeah.
I was fun though.
You could watch that on youtube
and then think about how sick I was.
Um,
yeah.
So anyways,
so that's,
that's my channel.
I'm really selling it.
You get more why?
I'm here a lot.
So,
uh,
I don't,
I'm not bored,
but I'll be bored on do I 30,
and then I will sometimes eat more food in a grocery store.
I look forward to sending,
you said something earlier about comp,
using comedy as the vehicle to like move things forward or writers started that
like sparked the conversation or it makes it easier to sort of,
to metabolize like,
yeah,
the issues around the issues,
you know,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean this isn't building is not a fun thing to talk about.
What you definitely touched on earlier,
right.
It's like that's sad,
right?
But,
uh,
but comedy is not,
so sometimes it depends on how good you are.
Hi.
[inaudible] at the Improv shows that were very sad.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
An improv group.
Yeah.
I made a couple and it's,
it's up escape rooms putting,
so there's a live sad comedy going on.
Um,
but uh,
it does,
it is a very,
uh,
it's a very good way to kind of break down a barrier that is not fun to talk
about.
And I kind allows you to talk about what you're doing versus the disability of
it.
And um,
I think that people are then seeing me as a comedian versus seeing my chair
first and then a comedian.
So I think I,
I um,
yeah,
I,
I like company for that reason.
Wonderful.
This point,
we're going to open it up to audience questions.
We have a microphone in each aisle.
If you want to approach the microphone and we'll do Q and a a while people,
if they're going to ask questions while people are doing that,
I have a couple of fun kind of rapid fire questions.
It will burn through them pretty quick.
Please.
One thing about questions though,
I'm the one thing that I say to anyone,
a is ask whatever you want and then anything you were afraid to ask.
Don't be,
don't be afraid.
Well we'll answer anything unless,
right Greg.
Well go for it.
Go for it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
who is most likely to try and get everyone to go out and party after a show or a
practice?
Not me.
I'm on a train.
Um,
I feel like Greg
brought up last night.
Well,
I don't know,
but,
so the eye,
it's Alex Bro,
uh,
is uh,
plays Eddie in who couldn't be here today.
Um,
it's just the two of us and,
and uh,
you know what guys,
you know,
we're doing our thing and the ladies are just like putting on music or hear him
laughing and having a good time.
They have a case of Jose and they're dressing room.
Like,
I don't think they're drinking before the show,
but after the show,
for sure
as deputy,
you can have one beverage for show.
It's true.
Yeah,
I knew that.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
so what book are you reading right now?
Oh,
I'm a,
I'm reading the alchemist and slowly reading it,
but yes,
I'm reading that right now.
I'm almost done.
It's good.
Like to that training.
Uh,
Sasha,
I think we have question.
Great job you guys.
Now I really got to go see the show.
Yeah,
we,
uh,
so this question or like the B train anybody,
but you mentioned doing the adlibs and sort of being really present.
And I was curious in particular for Shannon,
like wheelchairs,
they can break down sometimes and you get the equipment failure and stuff
happens.
And I thought it was really cool.
And that scene,
how you use it for really good comic effect.
Like the,
like Cory was saying,
going back and forth on.
But like what I like,
did you ever like your battery runs out in the middle of a scene or you're real,
you got a flat tire or have you,
does that ever happen?
I have solid rubber tires,
so I make sure that doesn't happen.
Um,
well,
one thing that was crazy and the show is that we got,
yeah.
Uh,
like,
uh,
a veneer put onto the stage.
And so my wheels were crazy squeaky and it was so terrible.
I definitely,
it was like the center of the show is what is our tennis shoes every day.
It was bad.
It was bad news bears.
Uh,
um,
but so that was a little stressful.
Um,
no batteries ever died.
I,
I had to get wheelchair repairs that my insurance won't pay for it.
Um,
that was a stressful time.
That has nothing to do with this show.
I don't know why I brought that up.
It's fine now.
Um,
Oh God,
I hate it.
I hate talking sometime.
I'm an actor.
No,
I mean I think,
um,
uh,
my wheel kits caught on,
on stage a bunch of times and I just kind of like pushed through written,
pretend it didn't happen.
My answer to your question,
I'm so sorry.
I'm sure it will.
Like,
do you ever feel like,
um,
it's like you have to educate other people.
So like if something
like that,
so I'd like to,
if you fall out of your chair at,
which does happen from time to time like that before you realize like you're
okay,
but then everyone else is going to get freaked out and your main job is to like
reassure them that said,
okay,
this happens.
Oh Wow.
You ever had that kind of feeling about that particular thing happening or other
stuff like that?
No.
Oh No.
Ah,
I wear a seatbelt.
Um,
I haven't seen people fall off the chair.
I have never fallen out of my chair.
A knock on wood somewhere.
Um,
yeah.
no,
I mean I think Greg and I talking about this and punch,
it's like,
you know,
we,
we were in Hersel's in and we would allow anyone to ask us questions because you
do often have to educate,
um,
because it's just not something people around.
And,
um,
we went out to lunch and I am Mernda and Sasha were talking about how they never
really noticed how many stairs there are in the city.
Um,
because it's just not something you realize like,
you know,
I realize it every day,
um,
when I'm in the pea elevators.
Um,
and so it's like,
you know,
it's just kind of that stuff that,
yes,
I feel like there is an educational piece of it,
but it's not something that like,
I'm never going to feel burdened by or anything like that.
I like having those conversations because it's,
um,
I don't know,
Greg can talk more about that,
but,
um,
I,
I'd rather you ask me then,
don't just assume.
Yeah,
cause we all know that phrase.
I like to say ask Google,
why does it
no,
but I think what you just mentioned is that I'm in,
I'm not a wheelchair user,
but again,
I,
I'm constantly negotiating that relationship of like anytime I meet someone new
and then we do this sort of strange social power to do it,
where it's like,
I know you see me in,
you're clocking something and it should we mention it and I have to put you at
ease and that you know,
that I'm an actual person and can talk and whatever and do all these things,
you know?
And I think that's,
that's just part of the experience,
you know?
And,
um,
but I'm actually fascinated by that,
that exchange.
Um,
and again,
that's why I think theater is a great vehicle,
this sort of exploration because you're,
we've,
we're always in relation to an audience as to say,
well,
people write and negotiating that theater is sort of an explosion of that,
of that idea where there's a frame and you can have control over sort of the
story that you're telling.
So that's,
I mean that's,
that's just a way to,
for me to sort of Rasul,
uh,
that,
that be stound.
Um,
and again,
it can,
I can,
I can choose where I want to engage and disengage.
And I just happened to start a company where like the whole purpose is to be a
platform for conversation.
So at this point in my life,
I may be talking more about it more than I like,
or you know,
should,
but I think that's just the need is there,
you know,
and again,
what art does in what theater does in particular is creating community as
Miranda said,
and creates an opportunity to discuss.
Right?
And I think rather than say,
let's talk about disability,
we're talking about this particular play where disability and,
and several other issues are present,
you know,
so if it comes up,
we'll talk about it and if not,
we'll also just talk about the play,
you know.
So I think that's,
I'm really interested in that,
that sort of overlap,
that exchange and that synergy.
Wonderful.
We have a question here,
Maddie.
Hi.
Uh,
thank you guys again,
so much for coming.
We're all so excited to have you here.
Um,
so you've already answered this question a little bit,
but I was really excited to ask.
Um,
but I wanted to talk again about,
uh,
using comedy as a storytelling device because the show seems so funny.
Um,
while also tackling really difficult issues.
I just wanted to ask if there were any challenges with that or if there was any
worry like that the audience may like misinterpret jokes or if you were ever
worried about like,
um,
like trivializing anything.
Uh,
so that's my question.
Hmm.
No,
you can just read it.
Yeah,
yea,
yeah.
I think anything,
you know,
just from myself and it was a compensated with Mike and Moritz,
the director and everyone will be opened into the cast.
Like again,
like we're,
we're hitting on things like,
you know,
there's some language that might be considered offensive in this show.
There's,
you know,
but everybody's fair game basically.
And for the comedy to be successful,
you really have to lean into it.
You can't shy away from it.
You have to be as sort of mean or rude or,
or,
uh,
um,
insensitive,
uh,
through the character.
Right.
Uh,
cause it's a very respectful ensemble of wonderful people.
Um,
but I think in order for that comment a work,
yeah,
it has to be played,
you know,
seriously.
And for all it's worth.
So again,
when we had to have those discussions,
and I think the,
everyone on that stage and in the,
in the process is game to that.
If someone wasn't,
then they wouldn't be involved in this.
And I mean,
again,
that's,
that's intentional for,
again,
from my,
from my point of view,
to sort of really tackle that.
And again,
it's hopefully we're,
we aren't getting loud.
Like it's a funny,
funny play and Mike has done a fantastic job.
Um,
and what that does is bring is bring people in,
right.
And gets people on our side until the bridge
dramatically.
Then we can punch him in the guy.
But hopefully it gets people,
I mean,
again,
we had a,
um,
my aid a benefit night,
a Tuesday night.
And again,
we had this wonderful talk back and this woman was really a articulated her
whole sort of,
um,
sort of emotional process throughout the play of like being able to laugh and
then feeling conflicted and,
but it got her thinking and it got her thinking in a new way,
which regardless of the subject matter,
any great piece of art should,
should do.
That's the desired effect.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Um,
so back to a couple of questions again,
feel free to approach the Mike if you have any.
Um,
what is your greatest extravagance?
Like what is that thing that you're going to splurge on or treat yourself with?
Huh.
I'm going to Jamaica
welldyne booked it and for the 30th so the day after we close,
I am on a flight to Jamaica.
I'm taking myself on my birthday
because when's your birthday?
July 17th.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Right.
Except to gifts.
Yeah.
And so that's my extravagance right now and I'm just,
it's great.
It's great to have a vacation planned.
Yeah.
I've never really do that and I'm like,
it's something to look forward to.
So
I recommend nobody was able to do that.
Yeah.
Uh,
what is a word or phrase but you overuse.
Overused.
Okay.
Hi.
So many.
I think I say indeed a lot indeed.
Like I say that like,
just like that.
Yeah.
I don't know if
you don't do that,
cause I've never heard you say
maybe just in my head
or a word or phrase you think other people over you that kind of grinds know I
overuse Yaasss God,
everything.
I feel supported when you say that to me.
Oh good.
Yeah.
That's why I say it.
I mean I really,
it is a support.
It's affirmation is it?
It's like you go girl,
it's everything.
So enough.
That's why,
and I use it for everything.
So yes.
So probably too much.
Um,
what you would the best gift you've ever gotten.
Yeah.
MMM hmm.
Hmm.
I know you're,
you're giving yourself the gift of Jamaica.
Yeah,
that's it.
Thank you.
You answered my question.
Answered her photo.
You're
about to have it.
I know.
I remember
I was sick again,
cause that's oversee.
People always say that.
Uh,
no,
no.
My wife
setting up first.
She's due end of August,
so,
yeah.
That's pretty
fricking cool.
All right.
Yeah.
If you were a candy bar,
what candy bar would you be?
Does it have to be candy bar?
No,
it can be any candy.
Okay.
Skittles.
Oh yeah.
I would be a dark chocolate bar with almonds and a little common joy.
No,
no,
no.
That's good.
Dark chocolate.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not even a fan of this candy man,
but I would say a watch,
I'm gonna call it
a lot of those.
Yeah.
Also Carmelo's out out like
what's an electron?
Mcallen.
I don't know,
but
I feel like that sort of sums up me.
Right,
exactly.
People are like,
Huh?
What is that
like?
Weird.
I like it.
Do I like it?
I Dunno.
Yeah.
What about you?
Seven.
Oh Gosh.
Uh,
well I,
I like so many problem I made.
I'm just thinking about all the candy I want to eat right now.
Um,
I don't know.
I'd probably be like a nut outrageous or something like
out y'all,
you bring in a rag out of red wrapper razor yellow,
orange.
I don't remember.
I don't know.
Yes.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But she also put me onto the smurfs.
Tommy's smurfs though.
Yes,
dude.
Just Fyi,
those come back because of the movies.
They're always in five below.
I just eat them.
Oh,
good.
we have another question.
So here's my rapid fire question.
Olivier or McKellen
whoa.
Third or just in general as Richard.
Oh Man.
No,
in all seriousness though.
Oh,
okay.
So
yeah,
you're setting this thing in high school and having all of the characters are
most of the characters as teenagers.
How do you think that affected the way that you're telling this story
also?
Do you think that that might overshadow the message that you're trying to send
to some people?
That's a great question.
Yeah.
I think that what we've found and what's come up and talk backs is a lot of is
this is the high school aspect about the show and I feel like we all had that
experience of high school and we all harbor traumas that happened to us in high
school and like,
and that I think,
um,
and I,
and I imagined being in the audience for the show,
it all just comes right back as soon as you see the set and the lockers and the
backpacks and you're like,
oh,
I remember that athlete boy.
And I remember that weird girl,
you know,
like I feel like it,
it actually puts those of us who've been through high school back on that
playing field where the state where we remember what the stakes felt like and
what it was like to be unpopular and to want to be powerful and trying to find a
way to do that.
Now actual high school kids I think who have seen the show sometimes I feel like
it's too close to their reality in a way that it's like as adults I think we
have the advantage of getting to look back at it backwards.
But for them,
you know,
it's very closer to the bone.
And um,
interesting too in that way where it feels potent and s and an storyline in
particular is one that deals with um,
uh,
no spoiler alerts but just deals,
deals with some serious issues for teenage girls,
issues around sex and sexuality in a very real way.
And I,
and I had a conversation with a young,
younger woman who in high school who saw the show and it,
it was serious for her.
I was like,
what,
what going,
how did you prepare for that?
How did you know?
I was like,
ah yeah,
thanks for reminding me.
Like this is reality l out there.
So yeah,
that's a great question.
I mean I,
I think I would love to see this play perform where people who were closer to
the age,
if not the actual age is,
I think there's room for that.
But I think Mike and I had the playwright and I had a lot of conversations back
and forth initially about who this plays for and what the type of audiences for
and again are the age range has been
okay.
Pretty broad.
But I think there's,
this is what the version of this play is now for its,
its premiere and it's based on who,
who started in and I was,
I mean it was far too old to play with,
you know,
when the show started.
Uh,
or was the first commission.
But again,
I think,
yeah,
I think we agreed because of Mike's language and people having an avail
availability and,
and skill to do that.
We decided to go older,
but there are plenty of talented young,
younger people who could certainly play it.
I think that'd be really interesting once the now what's great,
the best play we'll be out in the world like it has been launched.
Right.
And so,
um,
and that would be up to Mike to decide,
whether if anyone approaches him high school or college from what not to do that
he can,
he can give it its blessing or not
when,
I'm sure high school would definitely be willing to do this.
And I will also say,
uh,
your story about the a squeaking wheels,
as a high schooler who did have to actually carry around disability equipment.
Yeah,
that would probably make it a little bit more realistic.
Oh,
you liked the element of the,
of the house.
He was just very loud and you couldn't hear anything I was saying
that would definitely help.
In my case it was Michelle impairment equipment.
Well,
wasn't too in the way,
but it was definitely a hallmark of me.
Sure.
Yeah.
Very nice.
Thank you.
Draw that line,
that line between total reality and then kind of,
yeah,
sure.
For the dialogue.
We're not,
might still,
it was,
it was a little too loud.
Um,
so we're actually at time.
Uh,
I just wanted to say thank you guys so much for taking the time.
I know they have a show tonight.
I'm at the public theater.
I highly encourage you all get tickets to go watch the show live 29.
Yeah.
I just really,
really wonderful,
funny show.
Um,
so thank you guys.
Thanks.
Thank you.